hi I'm Christopher hin and today we're
going to talk about
Shon so I just want to talk about shag
today so I'm going to give you some tips
and tricks just like you came to one of
my classes and I decided it was shag day
that's what we're going to do so I'm
gonna get Josh over here we're going to
go to work
[Music]
Josh all right so let's talk about shag
I don't have any super special stuff
planned I just kind of want to talk to
you about what Shaga is and and um kind
of some of the understandings I came to
with shag and and what I think it's
actually doing so I think shag is
basically born of suto moari it's
particularly fond of suto moari from
katate Dori and you should always think
of it initially as hoki right and so
that's that's where I think the the root
of the Shag is and and then everything
else can be borne off of that and
there's lots of other ways we can get at
it you know we can get it from the
shuchi and get at it from all kinds of
stuff right okay so let's look at katori
right okay so I have katatori now the
uraza Shag I believe is much more native
than the otaza Shag although there's
good reason for both of them but let's
just look at the basic idea of Tino and
first I'll do it like you see in in a
lot of schools so
koho which is this boom that's the real
classic uh description of uh that now
why would I want to do that well I mean
there's lots of reasons I could do it
but if I'm not working on this hand I'm
really not doing myself a a service so
really I believe that technique should
often be shown a little more like this
right so see I'm popping free so all I
do is make a slight adjustment here boom
and I pop free okay now a problem that I
could have with that is as I go to do
that he stays stuck to me okay so what
do I do when he stays stuck to me of
course I could transition into other
techniques right so like triangle or
anything else so I come here he comes
around and boom I could try and get free
with a triangle or something but
continuing to turn is a really natural
thing to do and I see my kids do it all
the time my kids actually set up shag
rather a lot when we do hoki stuff
because they just like to turn and turn
and turn and turn turn right so if I
turn here and Josh keeps holding on to
me continuing to turn is a really really
natural thing now if we think that we
have to get into that final position
right so the position where Josh is like
this which some schools call nanako
right so up in this kind of contorted
position where you're you're pulling the
shoulder out of place um
if we think that it has to end in that
then we're going to have real difficulty
with our shag and the reason is because
to make that timing work off work out
meaning I set up in my mind like I want
to get a shag right and so to get the
Shag this is what I have to do we're
very very often not going to get it
because it's a lot of time for him to
decide to do something else right so
meaning that I'm like okay I'm going to
do shag and Josh feels me doing that and
he decides to do some other right
let go of me and come around and grab me
he could do all kind of right so like
let's say Josh is doing shag and I feel
oh he's setting me up for shag well I'm
going to do this right all kinds of
things okay but if my whole idea of the
Shion is I want to get this hand free
and he thinks he's thwarting Me by
keeping a hold of my hand well I'll keep
entering entering entering he'll keep
sticking sticking sticking what happens
is he gets shag and he gets shag really
really naturally okay so that I believe
is the the most natural root of shag so
if I wanted to just give you what the
root of is that's what I'd give you so
that's where we started now tons of
stuff can happen because of that route
right so one thing we can get out of
this is
sha and I'll show you a classic way
that's shown in dto to you if I can if I
can end up getting Josh to do it we'll
see okay so I come 90 so this is the
setup for our Ulta and then I apply this
to Josh let's see if I can get it is he
going to do it there we go we got him
right and we see that sh nag right okay
so that is you know and when you see it
in like a d demonstration so do mul you
see
this right it's like you know they
really like to play it out but that's
basically the idea I'm cranking the crap
out of his arm because I'm cranking it
so hard he just starts turning in the
Shag right and so he does essentially
the same thing that I was doing I just
wanted to turn before to keep a hold of
him but now because I'm turning him so
hard he's turning all on his own right
so look at him turn all on his own bang
okay
now that sets up a myriad of ideas for
the ult right and so my favorite way to
show the ult is we go here and I come
into here to try and get hoki this way
right so this is basically a roio now as
I try to get this he pulls his arm in
really hard right so he's strong like
this and as he pulls that arm in I just
turn with it bang and we get the omoa
shagi out of that right so because he's
interrupted my cycle of trying to crank
that arm him pulling in to stop that
cycle actually facilitates me turning
with it to make the Shag again all right
now we're just talking about core shag
and what shag should have in it I think
one of the the most core ideas to Shag
that everyone forgets is that you should
be separating the body from the hand
like that right okay now if we're
worried about him holding on to me
because I want to turn and and make the
picturesque Shion I'm not going to get
that very often which leads to a lot of
bad shagas so that's why you see stuff
like
this right these is a really bad example
of shag instead of stuff like this right
to turn now Josh and Maya can tell you
they've had my shag before it feels like
your arm's going to get ripped out of
socket right and I think if I did it as
hard as I could I might very well rip an
arm out of socket right because I'm
separating that arm as much as I can and
this is what leads to the really nice
balance breaking right so the kazushi
that you want your shag is because of
that extreme extension now if I'm super
locked on the idea of I've got a turn
I'm going to put more into my turning
fast to try try get sh and put myself in
a weak position then if I'm just want to
clear my hand right so if I just want to
clear my hand probably what's going to
happen 90% of the time is that right
which is a better technique for me
because it's less involved for me comes
off quicker less for him to do with it
than if I try to get the Shag and only
if the UK is so flexible and fast that
he can stick with me will that naturally
arise right so that's another reason
that we would get into that that shag
okay another big problem you see with
shag is people love to end side by side
I think it seems cool to them or it's
what they pictured in their head or
whatever but so they turn shag and we
end up in this position okay this
position sucks because Josh can turn
right towards me right so he can hit me
he can stab me he can kick me all kinds
of stuff real bad for me I want to
finish my shag here this is where I want
to be now if Josh tries to hit me kick
me bite me whatever he tries to do it
doesn't matter because I'm clearly
behind him so it's real hard for him to
do anything this also makes available to
me a nasty kodish up here and that kotay
can disarm him so if I was trying to
take a weapon out of his hand I can
disarm him really well with that and if
he's holding on to me real securely I
can wrench my hand out really really
strongly with that kot so only when I
get a really stable position like that
do I get a true kodish setup inside and
that's sometimes called Ten Kai kodish
in some schools of iido where I'm
getting a so tenai means kind of like
kiten same kind of thing where I'm going
around up high and I'm twisting that
that kod sometimes it's called Ten Kai
koday but again everything's facilitated
because of the Turning action and not
because of my desire to throw him with
this action and so what we tend to
confuse in our head is this is Shag and
it's really not the turn is Shag whether
he's turning because I'm cranking on him
so much or because he's pulling me back
and I'm going to get pulled off balance
or because I'm just trying to make a
suto moari action and he's sticking to
me it's always the four directions I
look at that create shag so shag is not
this shag is the position or whatever
happens from me turning like this and
that generally will lead to so if you
think of it more as good hoki instead of
a big throw you're going to get your
Shag in live practice way more and also
the techniqu is going to facilitate and
make much more sense to you as you
practice it that way right so meaning
that the technique will give you what
you want more often as hoki than it will
give you what you want as a big fancy
throw so uh I think that's it that's
that's basically what I tell you if you
were in my class I would make you do a
bunch of shag but other than that I
would give you basically that same
lesson so I'm Chris fry this is Joshua
my salano McDaniel is again behind the
center camera studiously studying all
right we'll see you in the next video
[Music]